[Musique]
Je vois la mort d'un roi et avec lui
son royaume c'est la règle houmous du commerce
de la guerre de bebbanburg arrive
les numéros de marge de Dane du nord au
sud quand je serai parti mon fils aura besoin que
tu sois trahi contre la
maladie des rois est  grand les ennemis du Wessex
j'offre des troubles et de la déloyauté envers
Alfred le royaume de Wessex se
rendra ou
[Applaudissements] des
rois seront faits et des rois mourront
la couronne est très importante je ne souhaite
pas devenir des enfants est votre devoir de vous faire Seigneur
va briser ta petite amie sur ta
gloire
tu dois défaire le passé tu dois détruire
Alfred
toi